And for young,
those were equivalent in
some sense to the loss gods.
And so for young,
your,
your interest was being manipulated behind
the scenes by unseen forces that were
associated with your character or
logical development across time.
That was the manifestation of the self.
So the self is this,
the,
the potential you,
let's say,
and the way it operates in the present
is by gripping your interest in directing
it somewhere.
And that's part of the
instinct of self realization.
It's a mind boggling idea,
man.
Really it's,
I think it's correct.
I,
I can't see how it can't be correct.
It doesn't mean I
understand it completely,
but it certainly seems
phenomenologically correct.
And I mean,
the potential that you are has to manifest
itself somehow in the here and now.
It has to.
And what better way than by
directing your attention,
you know,
it's like,
it seems like this might be useful for
you or maybe you get attracted to this
person.
Maybe you admire this person
that happens with kids a lot.
They'll admire someone and then copy them.
And you can see that that's obviously
part of their developmental progression,
right?
It's a form of hero worship,
but kids are very imitative and they
hear a worship at the drop of a hat,
and so they're,
they're entranced by the,
the next stage of development.
And if they see someone who embodies that,
especially if it's in the
zone of proximal development,
it's,
it's some,
it's something they could
achieve stretching a bit.
They find someone who embodies that
next stage of development and then they
start to imitate them and act like the,
well,
we're adults are no different.
We're no different.
We're just,
we do it at a perhaps more abstracted,
sophisticated level.